DEMOCRATS WORK TOGETHER TO PASS
A $2 TRILLION RELIEF BILL.
PETE: HERE TO REACT IS HOUSE
MINORITY WHIP AND LOUISIANA
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE.
CONGRESSMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE THIS MORNING
APPRECIATE IT.
>> GOOD MORNING GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY GREAT TO HAVE
GIVE US THE TOP LINE ON THIS ,
YOU KNOW, WE NEEDED SOMETHING
AND WE NEEDED IT QUICK.
IT’S A BIG PRICE TAG, WHAT ARE
WE GETTING AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
RESERVATIONS?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM LIKE WE HAVE WITH THE
ECONOMY REALLY BEING SHUT
DOWN IN MOST SECTORS FOR
OVER A WEEK NOW, YOU SAW
GREAT COMPANIES THAT WERE
LITERALLY HANGING ON BY A THREAD
THIS BILL WAS DESIGNED TO HELP
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE AN ECONOMY TO COME
BACK TO WHEN WE GET THROUGH
THIS THERE’S ALSO A LOT IN THERE
TO HELP HOSPITALS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TOO SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BILL, ANY LARGE BILL LIKE
THIS , AND PROBABLY THE LARGEST
RELIEF PACKAGE IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COMPANY OF $2.2 TRILLION BUT
CLEARLY A MASSIVE RESPONSE TO
ALL OF THE MASSIVE THINGS WE’RE
SEEING LAYOFFS, COMPANIES THAT
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF THEY
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THIS , THIS BILL WILL
REALLY GIVE THEM THAT ABILITY TO
GET LOANS THAT CAN BE FORGIVEN
TO KEEP THAT PAYROLL SO THAT YOU
DON’T SEE MILLIONS MORE
UNEMPLOYED LIKE YOU SAW JUST
LAST WEEK 3 MILLION PEOPLE THAT
WERE ADDED TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
ROLES, YOU CAN’T SEE AN ECONOMY
SUSTAIN ITSELF LIKE THAT, AND
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO HELP
THOSE FAMILIES, TO HELP THOSE
COMPANIES STAY AFLOAT
THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
JEDEDIAH: CONGRESSMAN I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT LOUISIANA BECAUSE
IT’S NOW EMERGING AS THE NEXT
POSSIBLE EPICENTER OF THE VIRUS
CASES IS CLIMBED 30% IN JUST 24
HOURS, SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT RIGHT NOW JUST TO TAKE A
LOOK AT LOUISIANA, 2,746 CASES,
119 DEATHS SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THE NEWS AND WHAT ARE YOU
HOPING FOR IN TERMS OF THE
APPROACH OF PEOPLE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN THAT
STATE?
>> YOU KNOW IN THE LAST WEEK,
WE SAW NEW ORLEANS POP-UP TO BE
ONE OF THE TOP HOTSPOTS NEXT
WITH NEW YORK, AND YOU KNOW,
WE’VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL CASES GOING INTO THE
HOSPITALS.
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT A WEEK
AND A HALF AGO, TO GET AN EXTRA
7,500 TESTS PER KITS AND SETUP A
NEW POD SITE, A PILOT PROGRAM IN
NEW ORLEANS SETUP IN A FEW OTHER
CITIES IN HOTSPOTS SO YOU CAN
TEST MORE PEOPLE OF COURSE THAT
MEANS THERE’S MORE POSITIVES BUT
THERE IS AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
CASES AND AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
DEATHS.
THERE’S A NURSING HOME FACILITY
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE WE’VE
ALREADY LOST 11 PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DIED AND MORE POSITIVE IN THAT
FACILITY.
WE’VE GOT CDC THAT SENT AN
EXPERT DOWN JUST THE OTHER
DAY.
I’VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR GOVERNOR, WITH OUR MAYOR AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN GET EVERYTHING WE
CAN FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO RECOGNIZE THE INCREASED
HOTSPOT IN NEW ORLEANS.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN YOU’RE
PREPARING THERE IN LOUISIANA AND
PARTICULARLY NEW ORLEANS LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
YOU KNOW, THE DEATH RATE THOUGH
SPECIFICALLY IN NEW ORLEANS
ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN 50% OF
THOSE ROUGHLY ONE OUT OF EVERY
10,000 NEW ORLEANS RESIDENT HAS
DIED OF CORONAVIRUS RIGHT NOW.
YOU HAVE PERHAPS A CRISIS, THE
LIKES OF WHICH WE HAVEN’T
SEEN OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK.
ARE YOU WORRIED YOU’VE GOT WHAT
YOU NEED?
>> WELL, ANY TIME YOU SEE THAT
NUMBER AND LIKE I SAID, 11
DEATHS AT ONE FACILITY IS
HEARTBREAKING.
IT’S ALARMING, BUT YOU SEE
EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER,
FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
CLEARLY LIKE ALL OF THE OTHER
PLACES IN THIS COUNTRY, WHERE
THEY’RE SEEING OUTBREAK, YOU
KNOW, WE STILL DON’T HAVE A CURE
THEY ARE TRYING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT NEW THERAPIES, SOME
THAT ARE PROVEN FOR OTHER THINGS
LIKE MALARIA BUT THERE’S NO ONE
SILVER BULLET FOR CORONAVIRUS,
SO WE’RE GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING.
I’VE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
HOSPITALS IN NEW ORLEANS, AND
THEY’RE DOING HEROIC WORK.
YOU ALL HAVE POINTED THAT OUT
TOO.
THEY ARE ON THE FRONTLINES BUT
STILL GOING AND HELPING PATIENTS
AND SETTING UP TESTING CLINICS
AT REMOTE LOCATIONS, SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GO THERE INSTEAD OF
THE HOSPITAL TO BE TESTED AND
THEN IF THEY HAVE SEVERE
PROBLEMS OBVIOUSLY YOU WANT THE
HOSPITALS NOW RESERVED FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
MOST SERIOUS ILLNESSES.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
WILL CERTAINLY BE PAYING A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO YOUR BACKYARD AS